when John broke up the Beatles as you
pointed out he did it why didn't you say
to yourself you know what I'm gonna keep
the Beatles going and I'll do it with
George and Ringo and I'll tell you why
because I think in a way maybe you even
underestimated how great George Harrison
was in the sense of a songwriter yes he
had contributed songs but you and John
wrote the majority this stuff but think
about it it would have been a
combination of your solo material from
that first album it could have been his
all things must pass material and the
Beatles would have been yeah mind
blowing Lee great you know when that's
like a family you know when families
break up it's to do with the emotional
and the emotional pain you know and you
can't just think of a smart idea like
that at the time you're hurting too much
and so it wasn't going to happen you
know we'd we'd been through too much and
I think we were just fed up with the
whole thing you know but I hear your
point well I mean do you think you
underestimated George Harrison as a
songwriter honestly because you take
your point I think it was easy to
underestimate George because me and John
like he said had always written most of
the stuff and it had most of the singles
you know and George was a late bloomer
as far as writing was concerned he
wasn't that interested in the beginning
but then he started to get interested
and boy did he bloom you know you
ridiculous greatest songs ever I mean
here comes the Sun how appropriate is
that so now you know yeah
you